well it turns out a lot of parents
across the country are fed up with the
public education system which we should
call the government school system
so much so that they're pulling their
kids out of public schools by the
truckloads and instead turning to
private schools christian schools
charter schools and homeschooling
according to an analysis from the
national alliance for public charter
schools during the 2020-2021 school year
charter school enrollment grew 7 percent
the largest increase in half a decade
same for private schools by comparison
district school enrollment dropped
precipitously in every state
to be exact 1.4 million students left
their government-run school district
1.4 million american kids with a new
lease on learning
now you can try to blame this on covid19
and shutdowns and jamming masks on
five-year-olds all you want
but the truth is
parents are also fed up with the marxist
curriculum being taught in government
schools we're done
we don't want our kids to be
indoctrinated with gender neutrality
nonsense the religion of climate change
and racist critical race theory
the left has completely captured our
public schools i can't say that more
emphatically
i was a public school kid i'm sure many
of you were too but the schools of
yesteryear are long gone
kids learning from home during covid19
exposed their parents to poisonous
curriculum like say the 1619 project
i call what happened the covid 1619
effect
parents have found the real virus
and it's in the textbooks it's the woke
versus the newly awake
and the only hope for our country is for
this trend to continue
joining me now former university
professor and author of black eye for
america how critical race theory is
burning down the house carol swain and
north carolina lieutenant governor mark
robinson thank you both for being here
carol let me let me start with you
is it a good thing that um you know a
million and a half american kids are
saying i'm out of public school it's a
wonderful thing it's something that a
lot of us have called for for a long
time pete and so i'm proud of american
parents who are pulling their children
out of public schools but the rest of us
whether we have children or not in the
public schools we need to stand up and
fight for the children who are trapped
and left behind they have rights too and
right now they have been abused by the
curriculum
well said uh lieutenant governor you you
were part of a report in north carolina
called the indoctrination in north
carolina public education report
is that what you believe at this day and
age is happening in a lot of our public
schools
absolutely i do i saw it firsthand with
my children when they were in high
school i saw it at the university level
myself when i was a adult student in the
university system and the entire time
that i have been been involved in
campaigning and now as lieutenant
governor folks have been reaching out to
me all across the state with these
concerns this is not as some politicians
have claimed a conspiracy driven issue
this is a serious issue that we really
need to tackle and our office is doing
everything that we can to do just that
you know what carol what are parents
missing that say well
you know my public school's okay maybe
there's a little bit of that stuff
when when you send your kids to a public
school
in that sense what are they missing out
of that they otherwise should be getting
well they're missing out of the fact
that the teachers are educated in
critical race theory and so they come
out of the departments of education at
the universities steeped in it it is in
the classrooms and
parents are just now excuse me learning
about something that has been going on
for a long time
and it takes away from academic learning
when advanced placement courses are
removed from schools
when standards are lowered for minority
students when messages are sent about
white privilege and minorities being
victims and racism being permanent
that's something that's very damaging
and it creates a hostile learning
environment for our students hostile
teaching environment for the teachers
it's not good for america we need to
keep pushing back
lieutenant governor have you been called
racist or on the wrong side of history
for daring to dare that
you know critical race theory or
diversity equity inclusion maybe isn't a
good thing in our public classrooms
oh absolutely we had a major news outlet
that featured a cartoon uh picturing me
and another member of the state school
board
a native american woman
as ku klux klansman because we simply
want to teach
what's right in history and what's right
in the classroom
we have been demonized by many of those
on the left but we choose not to listen
those voices we listen to those parents
and teachers and students who are
reaching out to us every day and
demanding that something be done about
this and that's exactly what we're going
to continue to do man i'm grateful for
you both those teachers unions have a
stranglehold on so many of these places
states can fight back as best they can
but the best option is for parents to
say if you can if you have the resources
the options i'm out of here i'm gonna
find i'm not gonna play by the
government's rules uh because my life my
kid's life is at stake thank you both
carol thank you lieutenant governor mark
robinson thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else